tenemos que fx es igual a 3x cuadrada
menos 18 x 81 sobre 6x cuadrada menos 54
y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar las ecuaciones de lajas into
estás horizontal y vertical te invito a
que le pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes
hacerlo por tu cuenta antes de que lo
hagamos juntos supongo que ya lo
intentaste así es que encontremos cada
una de ellas consideremos primero la
asiento está horizontal la 5º está
horizontal a ver si existe una de ellas
la asiento theory zone tal es aquella
recta aquella recta horizontal a la cual
se acerca la función cuando el valor
absoluto de x tiende a infinito cuando
el valor absoluto de x tiende a infinito
esto es a qué valor tienen de fx cuando
x tienda infinito ya qué valor tienen de
fx cuando x tiende a menos infinito hay
varias maneras de hacer esto para
empezar déjame
fx nuevamente por acá abajo esto es 3 x
cuadrado menos 18 x menos 81 todo esto
dividido entre 6 x cuadrada menos 54 y
aquí hay dos maneras de pensar en esto a
medida que x tiene valores cada vez más
grandes que el valor absoluto de x es
cada vez más grande los términos de
mayor orden arriba y abajo en la
fracción los términos de mayor orden en
el numerador y el denominador son los
que van a dominar y cuáles son estos
términos de mayor orden en el numerador
es 3x cuadrada y en el denominador es 6x
cuadrada así es que cuando el valor
absoluto de x tiende a infinito cuando
el valor absoluto de x tiende a infinito
estos dos términos van a dominar
así es que fx es aproximadamente igual a
3x cuadrada sobre 6x cuadrada estos
términos ya no van a pesar obviamente
menos 54 ya no va a crecer y menos 18 x
va a crecer mucho más lento que 3x
cuadrada los términos de mayor
son los que van a pesar así es que fx se
va a comportar como esto podemos
simplificar aquí estos términos en x
cuadrada f x se va a aproximar a 3
sextos que es igual a un medio podemos
decir entonces que hay una sintonización
tal en que igual a un medio otra manera
para calcular esto si no te gusta el
argumento digamos práctico que hemos
usado por el cual estos dos términos son
los que van a dominar es que podemos
dividir tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre x elevada a la mayor
potencia la que se encuentre ya sea el
numerador o el denominador así es que el
término de mayor orden es x cuadrado en
el numerador dividamos numerador y
denominador entre x cuadrada de echo x
cuadra es la mayor potencia tanto en el
numerador como el denominador dividamos
entonces tanto el numerador como el
denominador entre x cuadrada así es que
multiplicamos el numerador por uno entre
x cuadrada y multiplicamos el
denominador también por 1 entre x
cuadrada nota que no estamos afectando
la fracción pues estamos multiplicando
la x 1 estamos suponiendo que x es
distinta de 0 y esto nos da 3 x cuadrada
entre x cuadrada es igual a 3 menos 18
sobre x menos 81 sobre x cuadrada y eso
dividido entre 6x cuadrada entre x
cuadrada es 6 menos 54 sobre x cuadrada
y qué va a pasar para valores de x cada
vez más grandes es decir queremos
calcular el límite el límite cuando x
tiende a infinito y esto cuánto va a ser
bien este término este término y este
término tienden a cero así es que la
función se aproxima a tres sextos o un
medio
si queremos tomar el límite cuando x
tiende a menos infinito sería lo mismo
este este y este tienden a cero y la
función de nueva cuenta tiende a un
medio así es que esta es la cinta
horizontal ye igual a un medio pensemos
ahora en lajas into estás
verticales voy a hacerlo por acá
las síntomas
verticales así notas verticales si es
que existen y quizás hay más de una
comúnmente se piensa que la cinta está
vertical va a ocurrir cuando el
denominador se hace cero que es cuando
esta expresión racional no está definida
pero como veremos para este caso eso no
es exactamente así si únicamente hacemos
el denominador igual a cero no
necesariamente vamos a tener un asiento
está vertical definitivamente la función
está definida pero eso no basta para
encontrar la cinta está vertical
analicemos entonces este denominador
podemos factorizar lo como de hecho
vamos a factorizar numerador y
denominador vamos a hacerlo por aquí
fx es igual en el numerador podemos
sacar 3 como factor común
que multiplica a x cuadrada menos 6 x
menos 27 y en el denominador podemos
factorizar 6 6 que multiplica a x
cuadrada menos 9 y aquí podemos seguir
factor izando tanto numerador como
denominador tenemos que fx es igual a 3
que multiplica veamos los números que
multiplicados sean menos 27 y sumados
sean menos 6 menos 9 y más 3 parecen
funcionar esto es 3 por x menos 9 por x
+ 3 y el denominador es 6 y esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados que multiplica a
x menos 3 por x + 3 así que cuando se
hace el denominador cero bien el
denominador es igual a cero el
denominador es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a 3
x es igual a menos 3 ahora te invitó
nuevamente a que hagas una pausa en el
vídeo y pienses si estas dos son
síntomas verticales quizá te diste
cuenta que el numerador también se hace
cero cuando x es igual a menos 3 por lo
que podemos entonces simplificar esta
expresión a fin de que encontremos las
as into estás verticales vamos a hacer
esto para simplificar fx podemos dividir
entre x más 3 tanto el numerador como el
denominador sólo hay que tomar en cuenta
que esto está permitido para x distinto
de menos 3 y esto lo tenemos que tomar
en cuenta pues deseamos mantener la
igualdad y recuerda que la división
entre 0 no está permitida vamos a
escribirlo entonces acá abajo
fx es igual a dividimos entre x más 3
numerador y denominador para obtener que
es 3 por x menos 4 sobre 6 por x menos 3
y esto es válido para x distinto x
distinto de menos 3
observa que esta es una definición
equivalente a nuestra función original
pero tenemos que incluir esta condición
que estoy poniendo aquí para x distinto
de menos 3 pues la función original no
está definida para x igual a menos 3 x
igual a menos 3 no se encuentra en el
dominio de la función original y si
simplificamos estos términos en el
numerador y el denominador al
simplificar x + 3 tenemos que recordar
esto si nosotros simplemente pusiéramos
esto esta no sería la misma función
si te fijas esta expresión si está
definida para x igual a menos 3 y lo que
queremos es exactamente la misma función
así es que hemos encontrado un punto de
discontinuidad aquí y ahora ya podemos
considerarlas assynt o estás verticales
estas ocurren para los valores de x que
hacen 0 el denominador pero que no hacen
0 el numerador como vimos x igual a
menos tres hace cero tanto el
denominador como el numerador así es que
hay un asiento está vertical lo voy a
hacer en verde hay una a sin tota
así en total vertical a cinto está
vertical en x igual a tres cuando x es
igual a 3 se hace ser el denominador
pero no se hace 0 el numerador déjame
escribirlo aquí la cinta está vertical
es x igual a 3 ahora usando estas dos
piezas de información que hemos obtenido
aquí ya deberíamos de ser capaces de
hacer un bosquejo de la gráfica de la
función quizá necesitemos también
graficar algunos puntos para ver cómo se
comporta la función conforme se va
acercando a ambas así todas pero sí
quisiéramos esbozar la gráfica de hecho
sí sí vamos a hacerla vamos a hacerla
simplemente por diversión y también para
tener una imagen completa de cómo se
está comportando esta función la función
se va a ver más o menos así se va a ver
más o menos así no le estoy haciendo
escala este es uno y este es un medio
que igual a un medio es la cinta
horizontal ya igual un medio es la cinta
horizontal ésta
igual a un medio y tenemos una cinta
está vertical en x 3
aquí tenemos 12 mejor lo voy a hacer en
azul 123 no lo hice en escala bueno x y
lleno están en la misma escala aquí
tenemos la 5ta vertical en x igual a 3
pero tan solo con esto no podemos saber
cómo se ve la función quizás se ve así y
también por aquí viene así la función o
quizás aquí viene por acá o la mejor la
función viene por aquí y por acá fue la
mejor más bien viene por acá con esto
tenemos una idea de cómo podría ser la
función ya para verla más precisamente
necesitamos graficar algunos puntos
también hemos establecido claramente que
la función no está definida en x igual a
menos 3 déjame ubicar entonces x igual a
menos 3
aquí tenemos menos 12 menos tres
entonces no sabemos cómo es la función
como hemos dicho pero si la función
viniera por aquí aquí tendríamos que
cambiárselo más clara con la cinta está
aquí tendríamos el punto de
discontinuidad y la función vendría por
aquí con las a sin todas y por aquí
podría seguir esta rama o si la función
viniera por acá si la función minera por
aquí por arriba de la cinta está
entonces ahí estaría el punto de
discontinuidad y esta sería la cim total
ajustar ya cada vez más cerca del
asiento está aquí podría venir la otra
rama de la función o también podría
venir por acá abajo de nueva cuenta para
ver la forma precisa la función hay que
graficar algunos de sus puntos te invito
a que una vez terminado este vídeo
obtengas algunos puntos para que puedas
determinar la forma precisa de la
gráfica de la función